THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
REGIS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAFIERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO SKINNER [inaudible]
EARN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN.
FORMER STATE SENATOR RODRICK
RIGHT.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING.
WE WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SENATORS AND GUEST.
AN HONOR TO BE HERE TO CELEBRATE.
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT THAT
ALLOW WOMEN TO VOTE.
ALSO IT'S A GREAT DAY TO JUST
CELEBRATE WHITES TODAY AND ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATED.
YOU'LL RECALL THAT GOES BACK TO
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT IN A
BIPARTISAN FASHION. TO SIMPLY
BRING ABOUT GOOD WILL.
YOU KNOW I WAS READING THROUGH
SOME INSPIRATIONAL IDEAS WHEN I
RAN ACROSS THE WORDS OF RABBI
HAROLD KUSHNER.
ANY OF THE BOOK CALLED.
WHEN BAD THINGS HAPPEN? TO GOOD
PEOPLE.
IN THE FINAL ANALYSIS THE
QUESTION OF WHY BAD THINGS
HAPPEN TO GOOD PEOPLE.
TRANSLATED SELF INTO SOME VERY
DIFFERENT QUESTION.
NO LONGER ASKING WHY SOMETHING
HAPPENED BUT ASKING.
HOW WE WILL RESPOND WHAT WE
INTEND TO DO NOW THAT IT DOES
HAPPEN?
ARE YOU CAPABLE.
A FORGIVING AND ACCEPTING IN
LOVE A WORLD WHICH HAS
DISAPPOINTED YOU BY NOT BEING
PERFECT.
A WORLD IN WHICH THERE IS SO
MUCH UNFAIRNESS CRUELTY DISEASE
CRIME AND EARTHQUAKES.
CAN YOU FORGIVE ITS
IMPERFECTIONS AND LOVE IT
BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY WORLD
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
ARE YOU CAPABLE OF FORGIVING AND
LOVING PEOPLE AROUND YOU EVEN IF
THEY HURT YOU AND LET YOU DOWN
BY NOT BING PERFECT.
CAN YOU FORGIVE THEM AND LOVE
THEM BECAUSE THERE AREN'T MANY
PERFECT PEOPLE AROUND.
AND BECAUSE THE PENALTY FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO LOVE HIM PERFECT
PEOPLE.
IS CONDEMNING ONESELF THE
LONELINESS.
ARE YOU CAPABLE OF FORGIVING A
LOVING GOD EVEN WHEN YOU FOUND
OUT THAT HE IS NOT PERFECT EVEN
WHEN HE IS LET YOU DOWN AND
DISAPPOINTED YOU.
ARE PERMITTING BAD LOOK FITNESS
AND CRUELTY IN HIS WORLD.
AND PERMITTING SOME OF THOSE
THINGS TO HAPPEN TO YOU.
CAN YOU LEARNED ELEVEN FORGET
HIM DESPITE HIS LIMITATIONS AS
JOE DOES.
AND DID YOU WANT TO LEARN TO
FORGIVE AND LOVE YOUR PARENTS.
EVEN THOUGH NOT AS WISE AS
STRONG OR AS PERFECT AS YOU
NEEDED THEM TO BE.
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN DO THESE
THINGS.
WILL YOU BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE ABILITY TO FORGIVE.
AND THE ABILITY TO LOVE OUR
WEAPONS GOD HAS GIVEN US BETTER
LABEL US TO LIVE FULLY.
BRAVELY AND MEANINGFULLY IN THIS
LESS THAN PERFECT WORLD.
MAY THIS BE GOD'S WILL.
A MAN.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THAT WAS GREAT -- TO DO THAT
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
I'M GOOD.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PRIVILEGES.
OF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
FIRST ITEM.
IS SENATOR STERN [inaudible]
NOW
.
SENATOR STERN ARE YOU PREPARED
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON ON THE IN
THE AGENDA [inaudible]
OKAY.
NEVERMIND WILL GO BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IF IF
WE COLOR SCHEMES YES HE GATHERED
HERE UNDER STERN.
USE ME WE PLEASE RESTORE.
WE'LL TAKE THE RESOLUTION AT
FIRST [inaudible]
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE A
CENTER STERN RELATIVE TO
PORTUGUESE NATIONAL HERITAGE
MONTH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- BACK IN THE LATE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
MY FAMILY THE MATOS FAMILY CAME
WEST SETTLED IN ALAMEDA.
AND UP IN THE NORTH PART OF THIS
STATE. TO GROW WALNUTS IN APRIL
CUTS AND DO THINGS THAT MANY
PORTUGUESE IMMIGRANTS DID. FOR
MANY YEARS -- BACK IN THE OLD
COUNTRY BUT AS WELL AS PART OF
THAT DIE ASPIRIN I'M HERE IS A
PROUD CALIFORNIAN OF PORTUGUESE
ANCESTRY TO PRESENT S. R..
FORTY FIVE WHICH WOULD RECOGNIZE
JUNE IS.
PORTUGUESE NATIONAL HERITAGE
MONTH. TO COMMEMORATE THE IMPACT
OF THE PORTUGUESE COMMUNITY
CALIFORNIA HERE SOME OF THE
PORTUGUESE CALIFORNIA FIRST. ONE
RODRIGUEZ CABRIO WAS THE FIRST
EUROPEAN ACTUALLY TO EXPLORE
WHAT IS NOW THE GOLDEN STATE
SAILING INTO THE SAN DIEGO BAY.
WAY BACK IN SEPTEMBER. FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO ONE OF THE FIRST GREAT
MIGRATIONS OF THE PORTUGUESE
CALIFORNIA GATE CAME DURING THE
GOLD RUSH.
NOT LONG FOR MY FAMILY CAME HERE.
MANY THE PORTUGUESE AMERICANS
WERE THE DESCENDANTS.
OF THE FIRST NORTH AMERICAN
PORTUGUESE SETTLERS WHO WERE
EXPELLED JEWS SEEKING REFUGE IN
HOLLAND DURING THE SEVENTEENTH
CENTURY BOUNCING FROM EUROPE TO
BRAZIL. TO THE EASTERN COLONIES
ALL THE WAY TO CALIFORNIA.
THEY CALL MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
LATINO.
AND BECAUSE OF THE HIDDEN
HISTORY MANY JEWISH AMERICANS
HERITAGE IN THE PORTUGUESE ROOTS
ARE NOT NOW KNOWN TO THIS DAY --
GIVEN IS PROUD HISTORY THOUGH.
AND THE RICH HERITAGE WE HAVE IN
THIS STATE -- CALIFORNIA SECTION
THE FIRST AND ONLY STAY WITH THE
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY BASED FOR
TEACHERS PLAN FOR TEACHING THE
PORTUGUESE LANGUAGE AND CULTURES.
FOR THOSE OF US IN CENTRAL
VALLEY AND FAMILIES UP AND DOWN
THE COAST WE KNOW THE RICHNESS
RICHNESS OF THAT CULTURE BUT IT
DOESN'T LIVE WITHOUT LANGUAGE.
PORTUGUESE CALIFORNIANS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE STATE IN
ITS HISTORY.
FROM FIXTURES IN SAN DIEGO.
THE DAIRY FARMERS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND ENTERTAINERS
IN LOS ANGELES.
LIKE MARY ASTOR IN TOM HANKS SEE.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE THE SAME
WITHOUT PORTUGUESE IMMIGRANTS
AND THEIR DESCENDANTS.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE HERE
TODAY WITH US ARE FORTY FIVE TO
HONOR THAT HISTORY AND CELEBRATE
THE EFFORTS UNDER WAY TO
PRESERVE AND PROMOTE IT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR MORE LIKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE YEARS AGO
AND SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE JEWISH IMMIGRANTS ARRIVED
AT THE DUTCH WEST INDIES.
COMPANY THE WEST INDIES COMPANY
AND IN NEW AMSTERDAM.
I THEY WERE GREETED BY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COLONY.
PETER STUYVESANT.
WHO WAS UNWILLING TO LET THEM
INTO THE COLONY?
HE WAS DUTCH REFORMED AND IF HE
LEADS.
JEWISH INDIVIDUALS AND THEN HE
WOULD HAVE TO LET LOOSE TURNS IN.
WOOD APPLET THE ROMAN CATHOLICS
IN ANY WITH AFFLECK QUAKERS IN
AND SO HE WROTE.
HEADQUARTERS [inaudible]
AND ISSUES HAD ARRIVED AS THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM LA BUT SANTA
MONICA STATED -- MALIBU -- THESE
JEWS WERE REFUGEES WHO FLED FROM
RECEIVE BRAZIL -- WHICH WAS A
DUTCH REPUBLIC.
BUT IT HAD JUST BEEN CONQUERED
BY THE PORTUGUESE.
THAT'S WHAT CAUSED HIM TO HEAD
NORTH AND AS SOMEONE OF DUTCH
DESCENT I'M NOT BITTER.
JUST WANNA LET MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
NO -- BECAUSE AFTER EVENTUALLY
MANHATTAN ISLAND NEW YORK.
NEW HAMPSHIRE WE CAN NEW YORK
CITY -- BECAUSE IT WAS ALSO
CONQUERED BY THE THE ENGLISH BUT
THIS LETTER WENT TO TO TO
AMSTERDAM AND CAME BACK.
AND IT SAID WE HAVE MANY JEWISH
SHAREHOLDERS.
WITH A LARGE AMOUNT OF CAPITAL
IN THE SHARES OF THIS COMPANY WE
THINK YOU SHOULD LET HIM IN
[inaudible]
SO.
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF WHAT A GREAT
MELTING POT THIS COUNTRY IS --
HAS SOMEONE WHO LIVED ON A JERRY
WE HAD PORTUGUESE DAIRYMAN --
NEIGHBORS -- AND SO WE ARE
BLESSED WITH THE GLORIOUS.
KIDS SO GOD BLESS THOSE
OBJECTION JEWISH DESCENT AND GOD
BLESS THE PORTUGUESE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AS OUR FIVE FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING THEN YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE -- THE GOOD
CENTER FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR
ROUNDING OUT.
IMPORTANT HISTORY OF IMMIGRATION
IN THIS STATE.
AND THANK YOU ALL IN ADVANCE FOR
STANDING UP FOR PORTUGUESE
AMERICANS IN PRESERVING THIS
CULTURE WITH AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO.
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM RAIL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE I WORK OUT SEE
[inaudible]
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
CENTER STERN MOVES A CALL.
SENATOR STERN YOU HAVE
INTRODUCTIONS TO MAKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS WERE HONORED HERE TODAY
BY TWO INDIVIDUALS.
JOINING US HERE ON THE FLOOR.
ANOTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS UP IN
THE GALLERY.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY THE
HONORABLE CONSUL GENERAL OF
PORTUGAL IN SAN FRANCISCO.
MARIA JOAO LOPEZ CARDOSO.
AND WE ALSO HAVE JANICE FORGES.
WHO IS NOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PORTUGUESE AMERICAN
COALITION KNOWN AS C. PACK?
THE CONSUL GENERALS A STRONG
pCOMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH COMMUNITY
LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
PRESERVE OUR HERITAGE.
MR GORGEOUS IS BEEN A TRUE
LEADER IN GETTING C. PACK --
ORGANIZED UNITED WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND CIVIC LEADERS WERE
CRUCIAL TO FACILITATE STRONGER
COLLABORATION IN OUR PORTUGUESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND HELP
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GREATER ADVOCACY ON BOTH
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR GUESTS AND KNOW
THAT AFTER WE WILL BE HAVING A
BRIEF RECEPTION WITH SOME
DELICIOUS.
PORTUGUESE SNACKS OF YOU DO NEED
A LUNCH -- YOU CAN JOIN US BUT
FOR NOW LET'S RECOGNIZE OR
IMPORTANT GUESTS HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
FROM
.
A WARM SENATE WELCOME TO OUR
GUESTS FROM PORTUGAL.
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
JOIN US TODAY.
HEY MOVING ON ON THE AGENDA.
NEXT ITEM IS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES COMMITTEE
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
THERE ARE US SENATOR DIED.
LOOKING FOR APPROVAL TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
[inaudible]
ANONYMOUS CONSENT [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU THAT WILL BE IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD.
WE'RE NOW ON THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE.
SENATE THIRD READING WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ITEMS NUMBER THREE AND
ITEMS NUMBER.
FOUR STARTING WITH ITEM.
NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE SENATOR LEYVA.
AT AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT S. R.
FORTY THREE WHICH RECOGNIZES
JUNE FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS THE ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF
CONGRESS PASSING THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENTAS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT TO THE
U. S. CONSTITUTION WAS RATIFIED
RATIFIED BY THIRTY SIX STATES.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND GRANTED
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR OVER
SEVENTY YEARS WOMEN BATTLED FOR
SUFFRAGE AND SINCE THEN WOMEN
HAD CONTINUED THE FIGHT FOR
GENDER EQUALITY.
THESE COURAGEOUS WOMEN FOUGHT
FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND IN THE
PROCESS FURTHER SOLIDIFIED THE
IMPORTANT MOVEMENT THAT
CONTINUES TODAY.
WHILE OTHER ETHNICITIES AND
RACES DIDN'T GAIN FULL VOTING
RIGHTS UNTIL DECADES LATER THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WAS A CLEAR
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
OVER A CENTURY AGO U. S.
SUFFRAGES CAREFULLY CHOSE THE
COLORS TO REPRESENT THEIR
MOVEMENT PURPLE WHITE.
AND GOLD THE COLORS WERE
TARGETED TOWARDS NEWSPAPERS THAT
IN THE DAY PRINTED IN BLACK AND
WHITE BUT ALSO SPECIFICALLY
CHOSE WHITE TO APPEAR NON
THREATENING AND MAKE IT HARDER.
FOR PEOPLE TO CRITICIZE THEIR
APPEARANCE TODAY WOMEN AROUND
THE COUNTRY CONTINUE TO WEAR
WHITE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT WE
MUST CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
WOMEN'S SUCCESSES.
AND ACHIEVEMENTS AND THAT OUR
WORK IS CERTAINLY NOT COMPLETE
AS AMERICANS WE HAVE THE POWER
TO CREATE CHANGE AND DEMAND THE
QUALITY NOT JUST FOR US NOW BUT
NOW.
BUT FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS I
ASKED THAT WE THINK AND WE HONOR
THE WOMEN WHO FOUGHT FOR THESE
RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE SECURED AN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR FIGHT
CONTINUES MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THE ANY IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I STAND AS THE ONLY FEMALE
ASIAN AMERICAN LAWMAKER IN THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
IT IS A PROFOUND FEELING.
IF I WAS BORN IN ANOTHER TIME I
WOULD NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
I WOULD NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
HAVE INFLUENCE OVER WHO
REPRESENTS ME IN THIS VERY
INSTITUTION.
AND TODAY I STAND BEFORE YOU AS
ONE REPRESENTING NEARLY A
MILLION PEOPLE FROM MY COMMUNITY
AND REASON OF CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
FOR BRING THIS RESOLUTION TO US.
THE HELP REMIND ALL OF US THAT
WHILE WE HAVE WORK TO DO ON THE
QUALITY.
WE HAVE MADE SO MUCH PROGRESS
AND WE SHOULD NOT FORGET HOW FAR
WE HAVE COME.
AND AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION I STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR DRAWS A THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
IT TOOK DECADES AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT. TO MAKE VOTING A
REALITY FOR MANY WOMEN IN OUR
COUNTRY.
STILL TODAY WOMEN OF COLOR FACE
BARRIERS AN EXERCISE IN THIS
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS FACT REMEMBER
AND HONOR WOMEN OF COLOR WHO LED
THE FIGHT FOR SUFFRAGE.
SO JOURNAL TRUTH AND ACTIVISTS
AN ABOLITIONIST FOUGHT BRAVELY
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE FREE QUALITY.
SHE DELIVERED HER POWERFUL AIN'T
I A WOMAN SPEECH AT THE EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE WOMEN'S RIGHTS
CONVENTION IN OHIO AFTER FACING
EXCLUSION FROM MANY IN THE
MOVEMENT.
THE INFLUENCE OF IDA B. WELLS
INSPIRED MANY WOMEN TO ACTIVISM.
AND STILL RESONATES TODAY.
BORN INTO SLAVERY HE WAS A
GIFTED JOURNALIST AN ORGANIZER
WHO WORKED TIRELESSLY IN THE
ANTI LYNCHING EFFORTS.
DESPITE GREAT RISK TO HER OWN
LIFE.
HER DEVOTION TO JUSTICE AND
DEMOCRACY CULMINATED HER
TRANSFER ME TRANSFORMATIVE ROLE
IN THE SUFFRAGE MOVEMENT AND THE
ULTIMATE SUCCESS OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT.
LET US NEVER FORGET THE
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS OF THESE
COURAGEOUS WOMEN OF COLOR NGUYEN
SPIRED US TODAY TO SPEAK TRUTH
ABOUT EQUALITY I RISE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR -- IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
IT'S THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MADAM PRESIDENT IT'S SLICE IT
ALWAYS HAS A NICE RING TO IT
MADAM PRO TEM ALSO HAS A NICE
RING TO IT -- THIS WAS A LONG
HARD FOUGHT BATTLE.
IT TOOK DECADES FOR THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT TO BE
PASSED IT TOOK WOMEN WHO WERE
WILLING TO BE FORCE FED.
WHEN THEY WERE IMPRISONED?
IN ORDER TO MAKE A STATEMENT AND
IT COST MANY OF THEM THEIR
HEALTH IN SHORT IN THEIR LIVES
BUT IT IS SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN A SOCIETY THAT
CLAIMS TO BE ONE THAT CELEBRATE
TO QUALITY.
IT CELEBRATES EQUAL RIGHTS FOR
ALL THAT WE'VE HAD THIS BATTLE
BUT THIS BATTLE IS ONLY JUST
BEGUN AS WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL WEEKS.
THE EFFORT TO DENY WOMEN THERE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY IN LIFE BY
CONTROLLING THEIR OWN BODIES IS
SOMETHING THAT CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGE FOR US.
THE FACT THAT WOMEN ARE STILL
NOT PAID EQUALLY FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR WORK
WHETHER IT'S WOMEN OF COLOR OR
JUST WOMEN.
OVERALL IN OUR SOCIETY WE HAVE
NOT BEEN GIVEN THAT EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS OUR
BIRTHRIGHT THAT THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT REAFFIRMED WE ALSO
FIND OURSELVES THE VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IN THE WORKPLACE SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WE ARE A LONG WAY AWAY FROM THE
QUALITY BUT THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT BY THOSE THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN'S UPON WHOSE WHOSE
SHOULDERS WE NOW STAND.
DESERVE TO BE HONORED TODAY FOR
THEIR EFFORT THEIR DETERMINATION
AND THEIR PERSISTENCE AND WITH
THAT I RISE ALSO TO CELEBRATE
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT
RECOGNIZING THAT WE STILL HAVE
AN EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT THAT
WE NEED TO PASS.
AND EQUALITY IS STILL SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT QUITE WITHIN OUR
GRASP BUT WE GET CLOSER AND
CLOSER EVERY DAY WITH THE KIND
OF DETERMINATION THAT ALLOWS ME
TO SAY.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AS FAR FORTY
THREE AND I WISH TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TINA ALL.
OF FOR INTRODUCING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF RESOLUTIONS
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION WHICH
GUARANTEES WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
PIECE OF OUR HISTORY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TOWARDS EQUALITY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AS SUSAN B. ANTHONY ONCE THATTHIRD THERE NEVER WILL BE
COMPLETE EQUALITY UNTIL WOMEN
THEMSELVES.
CAN HELP MAKE LOSS AND A LACK
LAWMAKERS SOME VERY PROUD TO
STAND HERE ON THIS FLOOR AS I
LOOK AROUND TO SEE ALL MY FEMALE
COLLEAGUES WEARING WHITE.
AND PAYING TRIBUTE TO THOSE THAT
CAME BEFORE US SO TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO TAKE A MOMENT TO
HONOR.
ALL ROSE AND WHICH AS WE KNOW
WAS THE FIRST -- ELECTED SENATOR
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PAY TRIBUTE
TO OUR PRO TEN OUR FIRST FEMALE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PAY TRIBUTE
TO ALLOW ANY CALLING KNOCK IS
OUR FIRST LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AND THERE WILL BE MANY MANY
FIRST BUT FOR NOW.
I WANT TO THANK THESE.
TREMENDOUS LEADERS FOR FOR
BREAKING THE GLASS CEILING AND
ALLOWING US TO FOLLOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO WITH THAT I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MADAM PRO TEM ATKINS.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH I STAND AS A VERY PROUD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
AND CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE --
AND OF COURSE I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN SAID
THAT AS CALIFORNIA GOES SO GOES
THE REST OF THE NATION.
THE SENTIMENT APPLIES PERFECTLY
TO THE PASSAGE OF THE NATION'S
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION.
IN CALIFORNIA WE LET IN WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE BY GRANTING GRANTING I
MIGHT SAY WE WE USE THAT PHRASE
A LOT GRANTING.
GRANTING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IN NINETEEN ELEVEN NEARLY A
DECADE EARLIER THAN THE FEDERAL
RECOGNITION.
AGAIN IT JUST SOUNDS RIDICULOUS
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA TALKING ABOUT THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT.
I WAS A COLLEGE STUDENT WORKING
VERY HARD IN MY HOME STATE OF
VIRGINIA TO GET THAT PASSED.
IT SEEMS ILLOGICAL.
THAT THE EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT
IS SO CONTROVERSY ALL.
WE PROVIDE SO MANY -- EXAMPLES
OF INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP AND YET
STILL.
THAT IS CONTROVERSY WILL -- BUT
I WOULD SAY WELL WE CELEBRATE
THE AMENDMENT AND I APPRECIATE
THE RECOGNITION THAT WE'VE GIVEN
TO WOMEN.
WHO WITH THE SUPPORT OF PEOPLE
HERE HAVE RISEN TO POWERS OF
LEADERSHIP RECOGNIZE OUR OWN
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE -- WHO
WAS RIGHTLY RECOGNIZED IN HER --
WORDS THAT DAY ARE STILL -- AS
FILLED WITH THE IDEALS OF WHAT
IT MEANS FOR US TO BE IN THIS
CHAMBER ON THIS VERY CARPET AS
WOMEN -- I JUST I THOUGHT IT WAS
AN INCREDIBLE MOMENT AND WANTED
TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT AS WELL SO WHILE WE
CELEBRATE THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION I THINK WE NEED TO
KEEP IN MIND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
OUR WORK IN SETTING STANDARDS
FOR THE NATION TO FOLLOW.
NOT MOVE BACKWARDS ON MOVE
FORWARD OUR WORK TAKES ON
SPECIAL MEANING THESE DAYS IN
PARTICULAR AS OUR SISTERS
THROUGHOUT THE NATION FIGHT TO
PRESERVE THEIR VERY RIGHT TO
CONTROL THEIR OWN BODIES.
AND FUTURES AGAINST ONGOING
ATTACKS AT EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME AND MY
COLLEAGUES WHO'VE ALREADY SPOKEN
ON THIS RESOLUTION TO
COMMEMORATE THE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF CONGRESS PASSING
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT I ASK
FOR YOUR EYES OUT [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JOIN
WITH THE PRO TEM AND RECOGNIZING
THE ODDITY OF HAVING TO
RECOGNIZE A RIGHT THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN.
INALIENABLE AND NOT REQUIRE.
AN AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION.
BUT I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO THIS BODY TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE ONLY TWENTY SEVEN
WORDS IN THIS AMENDMENT.
THAT IS WE DEBATE ON THIS FLOOR
OFTEN ISSUES A BIG PRINCIPLE AND
BIG BILLS THAT ARE FULL OF A
NUMBER OF PAGES.
THAT SOMETIMES IT ONLY TAKES A
FEW WORDS THOUGHTFUL WORDS TO
ACTUALLY CHANGE THE COURSE OF
HISTORY IN THE APPROPRIATE
DIRECTION I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE [inaudible]
THING.
US SENATOR MORE LIKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER.
IN THIS MOVEMENT AND OCTOBER OF
NINETEEN ELEVEN PROPOSITION FOUR
WAS ON THE BALLOT. TO GRANT
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
IT WAS A RATHER INTERESTING
CAMPAIGN.
THE BALLOT MEASURE WAS SOUNDLY
DEFEATED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT BARELY PASSED IN LOS ANGELES.
AND AS THE BOATS.
RECOUNTED [inaudible]
IT PASSED.
WITH ONLY THREE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN VOTES
IN PAST ONE HUNDRED AND
250-003-72100 AND TWENTY ONE FOR
FIFTY BUT IT MADE CALIFORNIA THE
SIX STATE TO ALLOW WOMEN.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOLLOWING
OTHER WESTERN STATES WYOMING
COLORADO UTAH IDAHO AND
WASHINGTON SO I ENJOY --
CELEBRATING IN THIS ANNIVERSARY
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON S. R..
FORTY THREE THANKS VERY MUCH.
ST THING NO FURTHER.
I KNEW IT TO BE.
THING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
BATES CENTER LABOR YOU CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO STOOD AND IN SPOKE ON THE
RESOLUTION I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
SHE'S RIGHT WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND WHILE WE STILL HAVE
SO MUCH WORK TO DO I'M GOING TO
CHALLENGE EVERY WOMAN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EVERY WOMAN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
WOMEN REPRESENT 52% OF THIS
COUNTRY IF WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE CHANGE AND WE NEED TO USE
THIS AMENDMENT WE NEED TO USE
OUR RIGHT TO VOTE.
AND THEN WE WILL SEE REAL CHANGE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY THERE -- PLEASE.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BILL BY PORGES.
AYE BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
HI THAT ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
BY JONES.
HI LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN HI BY PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
I AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
LABOR MOVE THE CALL.
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE PROVISIONS
OF SENATE RULE FORTY FOUR WILL
BE AFFORDED TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CONFEREES FOR THIS
WEEK AND NEXT WEEK.
NOW WE GO BACK TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
FOUR SENATOR JACKSON'S
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE A SENATOR JACKSON
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA CANCER
SURVIVORS DAY.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CHANGING GEARS CHOSE
TO BID.
I RISE TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION WHICH COMMEMORATES
JUNE SECOND WHICH WAS YESTERDAY.
THIS CALIFORNIA CANCER SURVIVORS
DAY.
WHEN YOU GET TOLD BY A DOCTOR
THAT YOU HAVE CANCER?
YOUR HEART STOPS.
YOU CAN'T THINK ABOUT MUCH ELSE.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT
YOU NOW HAVE A LIFE THREATENING
DISEASE.
BUT I'M LIKE TWENTY YEARS AGO.
CANCER IN MANY RESPECTS IS NO
LONGER [inaudible]
LIFE THREATENING.
THERE ARE NOW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OVER EXCUSE ME IN AMERICA ALONE
WE HAVE FIFTEEN AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE.
AND WORLDWIDE OVER THIRTY TWO
WHO ARE ALIVE TODAY?
HAVING FOUGHT CANCER AND
SURVIVED.
AND I AM ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST
CANCER BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX AND I CAN TELL YOU WHEN
SOMEBODY TELLS YOU WHEN A DOCTOR
SOMEBODY YOU TRUST.
TELLS YOU YOU HAVE CANCER.
IT IS TRULY HARD [inaudible]
THE FOCUS [inaudible]
ON ANYTHING [inaudible]
AND YET.
HERE I AM TODAY.
DRIVING HALF YOU CRAZY.
BEING ABLE TO ENJOY THE
EXPERIENCE OF GRANDCHILDREN.
HAVING BEEN ABLE TO DANCE AT MY
DAUGHTER'S WEDDING.
HAVING BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT. TO SISTERS AND BROTHERS
WHO ALSO HAVE FOUGHT.
BREAST CANCER AND OTHER KINDS OF
CANCER IN HER STILL HERE TODAY.
THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH SUFFERING A WAR
MEETING THE CHALLENGE OF A
CANCER DIAGNOSIS.
THEIR PHYSICAL THEIR EMOTIONAL
SOME OF THEM HAVE LONG STANDING.
IMPACTS GOING FORWARD WHETHER
IT'S WITH YOUR HEALTH WHETHER
IT'S WITH YOUR PSYCHE.
BUT THERE IS A GIFT TO THIS
HORRIBLE DISEASE.
IT IS A GIFT THAT MAKES YOU
APPRECIATE EVERY DAY.
AND SO FOR THOSE OF MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHO WERE STANDING
HERE TODAY WITH ME.
WHO HAVE BATTLED AND WHO ARE
SURVIVORS OF CANCER WE CELEBRATE
THIS DAY?
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS
MUCH THAT WE CAN DO GOING
FORWARD AND MUCH TO GOING
FORWARD. TO ADDRESS THIS
INSIDIOUS DISEASE.
NOT EVERYONE WHO WAS HAD A
DIAGNOSIS IS ABLE TO SURVIVE IT.
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT WITH
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR TREATMENT
WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY ADVANCES
WE'VE MADE MEDICALLY WITH THE
AMAZING WORK OF DOCTORS AND
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE THERE TO HELP US SURVIVE
THIS.
IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE
SURVIVORS.
OUR HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
AND THE RIGHT OF EVERY PERSON.
WHO HEARS THAT DIAGNOSIS TO GET
THE BEST TREATMENT HUMANLY
POSSIBLE SO THAT THEY?
TOO CAN LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO
DANCE AT THEIR CHILDREN'S
WEDDING I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
JACKSON'S SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
CENTERS I APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
SHARE YOUR ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF S. C. R..
FIFTY FIVE AND AS SENATOR
JACKSON MENTION WHEN YOU HEAR
THOSE WORDS.
YOU HAVE CANCER.
YOUR HEART DOES STOP.
AND FOR ME IN MY SITUATION I WAS
THIRTY ONE YEARS OLD.
MY THIRD SON OUR THIRD CHILD MY
SECOND SON -- WAS SIX MONTHS OLD.
AND I STILL REMEMBER THAT DAY.
CLEARLY AT OF ANY DAY OF MY LIFE
CLEAR AS A BELL.
THAT DECEMBER AFTERNOON.
IREMEMBER THE CAR I WAS SITTING
IN.
I REMEMBER THE RAIN FALLING ON
THE WINDSHIELD.
I REMEMBER -- WONDERING HOW MY
GONNA TELL MY WIFE.
THAT -- THE SOLE BREAD WINNER OF
THE HOME [inaudible]
HAS CANCER.
AND FOR ME FORTUNATELY I HAD ONE
OF THE EASIEST CANCERS TO
OVERCOME.
BUT NOT EVERYBODY WHO HEARS
THOSE THREE WORDS.
IS IN -- FORTUNATE SITUATIONS I
WAS -- BUT I AM THANKFUL FOR ALL
OF THE CANCER RESEARCH THAT HAD
HAPPENED PRIOR. TO MY A
DIAGNOSIS.
AND ALL OF THE RESEARCH THAT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE MY DIAGNOSIS.
AND IT DOES GIVE YOU A HEART AND
A EMPATHY.
NOT JUST FOR CANCER ILLNESS BUT
FOR ANY ON THIS I THINK.
THAT -- SOMEBODY MIGHT BE
STRUGGLING WITH.
AND SO I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD.
AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTED
AND ASKED -- FOR THAT WE'D ALL
SUPPORTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR JOHN SENATOR
PAN.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I'VE MADE
IT IS HARD TO FOLLOW THE
ELOQUENCE MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SANTA BARBARA AND SHARING HER
OWN EXPERIENCES AND ALSO -- MILD
A COLLEAGUE AS WELL -- AND RIGHT
NOW I MYSELF HAVE NEVER HAD
CANCER -- BUT I'VE HAD FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE -- WHO'VE
PASSED AWAY FROM CANCER.
I SHOULD NOTE THAT THERE ARE
OVER FIFTEEN MILLION PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THE UNITED STATES OR
CANCER SURVIVORS -- THE ODDS OF
ANYONE OF US GETTING CANCERS
ABOUT 38% -- SOMETIME IN OUR
LIFETIME.
AND OFTENTIMES CERTAINLY IS I
THINK WAS ELOQUENTLY SHARED --
THE DIAGNOSIS OF CANCER
CERTAINLY.
FOCUSES ONE'S MIND IN A CERTAIN
WAY AND BUT ALSO ONE OF THE
REASON I'M HERE -- WHAT SPEAK UP
WAS THE ALSO SAY IS THAT WHILE
CERTAINLY WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO?
WHEN THEY GET THE DIAGNOSE
CANCER BEING TREATED WITH CANCER
WE RECOGNIZE THE THE CHALLENGES
THEY FACE IN THE FACT OUR
INVESTMENTS IN?
IMPROVING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
IN -- INVESTMENTS AND BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH HAVE EXTENDED OUR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
CANCER SURVIVORS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN BUT
ALSO A MAKE NOTE THAT.
WE CAN'T SAY THAT ONCE YOUR
CANCER SURVIVOR THAT THERE ARE
CONTINUING ON GOING NEEDS -- ON
GOING -- OUR ISSUES THE CONTINUE
TO DEAL WITH WHAT THE OF CANCER
AS A CHILD OR AS AN ADULT -- WE
TALK ABOUT PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS RIGHT IF YOU HAD
CANCERS THAT CANCER IS NOT WHAT
IS DISEASES WHERE IT'S LIKE OH
WELL YOU KNOW JUST HERE AND IT'S
GONE RIGHT IT.
IT'S SORT OF LINGERS AND WHAT
AND WHAT IS THAT SUPPOSED TO
MEAN IS IS YOU GO ON YOUR LIFE
EVEN WHEN IT SEEMS TO HAVE GONE
AWAY.
AND SO I THINK THAT CERTAINLY I
THINK THE CHALLENGE.
HERE TODAY FOR ALL OF US IS IS
THAT AS RECOGNIZE THIS
RESOLUTION AND CANCER SURVIVOR
DAY IS THAT THE THINK ABOUT THE
CANCER SURVIVORS AND THAT.
THE SURVIVORS THEY STILL NEED.
PEOPLE STILL NEED HELP AND WE
NEED TO BE HERE SUPPORT THEM AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
KIND OF ASSISTANCE -- TO OUR
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE IT
SAID. 38% OF US WILL EVENTUALLY
HAVE TO FACE THAT DIAGNOSIS
HOPEFULLY MANY OF US WILL MAKE
THROUGH IT.
BUT WE WILL STILL PERHAPS STILL
NEED HELP BEYOND -- THAT
DIAGNOSIS AND INITIAL TREATMENT
SO I URGE A SUPPORT AND I THINK
AGAIN MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA
BARBARA FOR BRING THIS UP PUT
RESOLUTION.
FOR SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR JACKSON YOU
MAY CONCLUDE YES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION AND TO TRULY WE
WILL SEE WE ALL HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE SUFFERED THROUGH A
CANCER DIAGNOSIS WE NEED TO DO
MORE BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE ARE
SURVIVING AND AS OUR POSITION
FROM SACRAMENTO POINTED OUT
THOSE NEEDS?
CONTINUE AND SO WE CELEBRATE
TODAY.
SURVIVORS BUT THIS IS ALSO A
CALL TO ACTION WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FIND MORE RESOURCES
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND.
THOSE ARE TREATMENTS FOR ALL
PEOPLE WHO MEET OR WHO.
FIND THEMSELVES HAVING TO MEET
THIS CHALLENGE WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE SURVIVOR FRIENDLY
LEGISLATION TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR CANCER
SURVIVORS.
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS ALL OF US
EITHER DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY SO
I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT NOT JUST FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
BUT FOR WHAT WE NEED TO DO GOING
FORWARD AS WE DEAL WITH THIS
MAJOR.
OUR THAT PEOPLE FACE IN LIFE
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL BY PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER I GROW.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LABOR.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK TIME A REAL.
BY NELSON.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
STERN BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
IOWA COUNTY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARE THOUGHT OF HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
ICE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
CENTERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SIX SENATOR ON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACE RELATIVE TO
REMEDY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS AYE.
I'M VERY HONORED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ACR
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZES
RAMADAN.
A MONTH OF SPICINESS AND
SPIRITUAL DEVOTION FOR MUSLIMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND OF COURSE
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
IT'S AUSPICIOUS TIMING TO BRING
THIS RESOLUTION TO THE SENATE
TODAY -- TONIGHT AS THE SUN SETS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
APPROXIMATELY NEARLY TWO BILLION
MUSLIMS WILL BREAK FAST.
IN OBSERVANCE OF IFTAR ON THE
FINAL DAY OF RAMADAN.
FASTING IS ONE OF ISLAM'S FIVE
HOLY PILLARS THROUGH WHICH
MUSLIMS DEVOTE THEMSELVES. TO
FAITH AND TO GOD.
CHARITIES THAT CUTS.
AS ANOTHER HOLY HILLARY COOLEY
OBLIGATORY AND AND VERY
IMPORTANT DURING THE SEASON.
IN THE COURSE OF JEWISH AND
MUSLIM HISTORY CULTURE AND
IDENTITY OR SO PROFOUNDLY --
TWINE IT WAS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY STRUCK ME WHILE
TRAVELLING TO THE MUSLIM WORLD
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG MAN -- WELL
NOT OVER A FULL MONTH JEWS
COURSE RECOGNIZE A HOLY DAY WE
FAST AND FOCUS ON FAITH AND SELF
GROWTH.
THE JEWISH RELIGION IS DEEP IN
THE VALUES OF THE DOCK AT
CHARITY WHICH IS CLOSELY.
RELATED TO THE MUSLIM PILLAR OF
ZAKAT AND OF COURSE THERE THE
TWO WORDS ARE ARE ARE CLOSELY
RELATED TO FROM OTHER SEMITIC
ROOTS.
SORRY JEWISH CAUCUSES VERY PROUD
OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE
ALONG SIDE CALIFORNIA'S MUSLIMS
TO GROW IN OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
ONE ANOTHER UNITED IN OUR SHARED
FIGHT.
AGAINST INTOLERANCE HI AS ALL OF
YOU KNOW OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
WITNESSED INSTEAD ALONGSIDE. ONE
ANOTHER IN THE AFTERMATH OF
DEADLY SHOOTINGS AT OUR PLACES
OF WORSHIP -- BUT WE'RE ALSO
DOING THINGS THAT ARE VERY
POSITIVE IN TRYING TO TO FIND
ROOM FOR GROWTH TOGETHER THE
CAUCUS IS WORKING WITH ISLAMIC
LEADERS. TO CREATE AN IN FOR
INTERFAITH PRAYER SPACE AT LA
ACTS AT THE AIRPORT. ONE OF MANY
PROJECTS WE ASPIRE TO WORK ON
WITH OUR MISS OF COMMUNITIES WE
HAD A TIME TO HEAL AND MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER AND SO IN THE
SPIRIT OF RAMADAN AYE.
I URGE ALL OF US IN THE SENATE
TO DEEPEN OUR COLLECTIVE
INVESTMENT IN THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY.
LET US WORK TO MENTOR MUSLIM
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A
LEGISLATOR HERE WAS OF MUSLIM
FAITH. ONE DAY -- LETTUCE
SUPPORT A LETTUCE OF AGENDA THAT
RESPECTS CALIFORNIA'S IT HERE
IT'S OF A SLUM.
AND TO MY MUSLIM SISTERS AND
BROTHERS I SAY RAMADAN MUBARAK
HAPPY RAMADAN.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON EACH YEAR.
EIGHTY FIVE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
SINGMAN.
OF THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
ELIGIBLE FOR IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SAYING NO OBJECTION.
I THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
ACTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ITEM.
NUMBER FIVE SR FORTY FIVE
SENATOR STERN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MITCHELL ROTH SKINNER.
I THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSED THE RESOLUTION
PASSES ITEM NUMBER THREE WE'RE
GONNA LIFT THE CALL ON S. R.
FORTY THREE SENATOR LEYVA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I ROTH SKINNER.
MEASURE PASSES RESOLUTION PASSES
FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO ADDRESS THE
ADJOURNING MEMORIES [inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO CHURN
IN THE MEMORY OF DOCTOR LISA
NIGHT.
WHO PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY ON
MAY TENTH AT HER HOME IN NORTH
HOLLYWOOD?
DOCTOR KNIGHT WAS SIXTY ONE
YEARS OLD AND SERVED IN THE
CARDIOVASCULAR NURSING CENTER AT
UCLA MEDICAL CENTER FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS.
AS A NURSE COORDINATOR FOR THE
PEDIATRIC ELECTRO PHYSIOLOGY
SERVICES LEASE TO WORK ON
PAEDIATRIC CARDIOLOGISTS DOCTOR
KEVIN SHANNON. ONE DAY DOCTOR
SHANNON CAME UP OF IDEA.
A CAMP IN CALIFORNIA FOR
CHILDREN OF HEART DISEASE.
LEASES RESPONSE.
WE CAN DO THAT.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SHE DID.
SO IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
DREAM OF HELPING CHILDREN HEART
DISEASE BECAME A REALITY.
AND CAMP DEL CORAZON WAS BORN.
ON THE ISLAND OF CATALINA. FOR
THE PAST TWENTY FOUR YEARS LEASE
AND DOCTOR SHANNON HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING A FREE MEDICALLY
SUPERVISED RESIDENTIAL SUMMER
CAMP. FOR CHILDREN LIVING WITH
HEART DISEASE.
MANY OF THE KIDS AT HEART
TRANSPLANTS IT WAS NICE TO BE
ABLE TO GO SOME PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD SEE A SCAR.
ON THEIR CHEST AND REALIZE THAT
THERE WERE NO DIFFERENT THAN.
THOSE THAT WERE THERE TO HAVE
SOME TIME OF FUN -- WITH KIDS
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH SOME OF
THE EXPERIENCES THAT THEY HAD
BEEN THROUGH.
CAMP -- CORAZON IS GROUND TO BE
A YEAR ROUND RESOURCE FOR
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN YOUNG
ADULTS AND FAMILIES AFFECTED BY
HEART CONDITIONS.
JUST IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ALONE THE CAMP PROVIDED SUPPORT
FOR OVER SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
INCLUDING THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX CHILDREN.
WHO ATTENDED THE CAMP?
LISA NIGHTS CAMP WAS NAMED XENA
WHO IS A WARRIOR GODDESS AND
GREEK MYTHOLOGY.
AGREED.
SB THAT NAME FIT HER PERFECTLY.
XENA BATTLED HER CANCER FOR MANY
YEARS AND SHE GAVE US HOPE THAT
SHE WOULD DEFEATED.
ALTHOUGH SHE LOST THIS BATTLE
HER LEGACY IT CAN'T BILL CORAZON
WERE FOR EVER LIVE.
ON AND BE FELT BY CHILDREN IN
FAMILIES FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
OUR PATHS CROSSED BECAUSE WE
USED TO HAVE FUND RAISERS AND
TEMECULA -- HAD A VERY -- DEAR
FRIEND -- WHOSE DAUGHTER DOBBY --
HAD OPEN HEART SURGERY AND
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE COMBAT A VERY YOUNG AGE AND
IN HONOR OF HER DAUGHTER BOBBI --
SHE GOT INVOLVED WITH THIS CAMP
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IF THERE WAS A PERSON WHO HAD
CARDIO VASCULAR DISEASE HAD OPEN
HEART SURGERY AND WANTED TO GO
TO THIS EXPENSE OF CAMPING
IMAGINE THESE CAMPS ARE STAFFED
BY DOCTORS AND NURSES AND
VOLUNTEERS.
IT WASN'T SHEAND SHE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE ALONG WITH DOCTOR
NIGHT THAT EVERY KID HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO THIS CAMP
WHERE THEY CAN AFFORD IT.
OR THEY COULDN'T AFFORD IT.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADJOURN.
THE OPPORTUNITY IN THE MEMORY OF
THE SELFLESS AND INSPIRATIONAL
WARRIOR.
WHO NOT ONLY SAVE LIVES BUT ALSO
GAVE OF?
JOY TO ALL THOSE THAT SHE TOUCH
BY ALLOWING THEM TO GO THE CAMP
DEL CORAZON MAY SHE REST IN
PEACE THANK YOU FOR LINE WITH
INTERNAL MEMORY.
PLEASE BRING BRING THE NAME OF
DOCTOR NIGHT TO THE DESK AND
EXTEND THE CONDOLENCE TO THE
NIGHT FAMILY [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE --
THIS AFTERNOON NOW TO ENSURE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF STEVE
SWARTS A DEAR FRIEND IN THE LATE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF SAN
CLEMENTE AND MY DISTRICT.
A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STEVE SERVED OUR
COUNTRY WITH THE UNITED STATES
AIR FORCE DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
AFTER HIS MILITARY SERVICE STEVE
ENTERED THE BANKING INDUSTRY
EVENTUALLY STARTING HIS OWN
BUSINESS IN SAN COMMITTEE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE OVER THE
YEARS HE BUILT HIS COMPANY INTO
A NATIONAL AGENCY.
SUPPORTING THOUSANDS OF
INSURANCE BROKERS AND DIRECT
ACCOUNTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY HE
SAT AMONG THE FOUNDING MEMBERS
OF THE SAME COMMITTEE COASTAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WAS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY AND WAS
CHAIRMAN OF THE SANTA MANY
BEACHES.
PARKS AND RECREATION COMMISSION.
OUR HE BEGAN HIS TIME INFORMAL
PUBLIC SERVICE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL HE WAS JUST INSTALLED AS
MAYOR.
THIS PAST DECEMBER HE WAS
DEDICATED ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HELP CHILDREN FIRST AND FOREMOST
HAVING HAD POLIO AS A CHILD HE
RAISE MONEY FOR THE ROTARY IS
POLIO PLUS PROGRAM.
HIS OTHER PASSION WAS RAISING
FUNDS FOR AUTISM IN COORDINATION
WITH AUTISM SPEAKS STEVE SADLY
PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY ON MAY
EIGHTH WHILE ON VACATION WITH
HIS FAMILY IN PALM SPRINGS.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
MORE THAN THIRTY TWO YEARS NICKY
AND THEIR SON KYLE.
STEVE LEADERSHIP AND SERVICE
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY OUR
COMMUNITY OVER TWO HUNDRED SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENTS ATTENDED
MEMORIAL SERVICES.
HELD IN HIS HONOR WHICH
REFLECTED THE AFFECTION AND
RESPECT HE EARNED AS A COMMITTED
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER AND
BUSINESSMEN.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN
STEVE'S MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
PLEASE BRING THE NAME OF MISTER
SCHWARTZ TO THE DESK SO THAT HE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZING
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
[inaudible]
SENATOR -- ATKINS.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WE WILL RECONVENE.
ON THURSDAY HAVE AN A A FAIRLY
EASY DAY TODAY -- WE ALL WORKED
VERY HARD LAST WEEK HOPE YOU GOT
A LOT OF REST -- BECAUSE NOW WE
PICK UP AND WE STARTED A NEW
PROCESS -- YOU NOTICED.
WE HAD SOME CONFEREES NOT HERE
THAT IS THE PROCESS WE ARE NOW
IN FOR BUDGET.
AND WE'VE GOT ANOTHER LONG TWO
WEEKS AHEAD OF US BUT TODAY WE
CAN WE CAN LEAVE EARLY BUT I
WILL SEE YOU AGAIN THURSDAY JUNE
SIXTH.
AT NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MEMBERS
CHERRY LEYVA OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS HAS ASKED THAT THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS MEMBERS STAY
AFTER FOR THE OBLIGATORY RIGHT --
SUDESTE PICTURE.
SO THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
SENATORS